madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame le rapporteur
mes chers collègues permettez moi de
saluer la constance et la technicité de
nos commissaires aux lois qui symbolise
l'esprit d'équilibré de responsabilité
propre au sénat je le dis à cette
tribune sous le regard de michel de
l'hôpital et de françois d'aguesseau
dont la rigueur n'avait d'égal que
l'esprit de tolérance
c'est parce que nous veillons à
l'exécution de peines proportionnées que
nous mettons un point d'honneur à
parfaire le droit ou à combler des
carences observées
jeu renverserait un célèbre adage pour
vous dire ce que nous refusons tous ici
en matière antiterroriste
agité une main de velours dans un gant
de fer
c'est dans cet esprit exigeant et
proactive que nous traitons ce jour
d'une problématique sécuritaire aux
atours de défi civilisationnel
je veux bien sûr saluer le travail de
mes collègues muriel jourda et françois
noël buffet qui animé par les exigences
de l'état de droit sont parvenus à
corriger un vide juridique
particulièrement inquiétant pour la
sécurité des français
nous connaissons tous ici les chiffres
qui nous conduisent à anticiper des
sorties sèches qui nous inquiète mais
nous partageons également la conviction
qu'il faut aller plus loin et imaginer
une réforme de structure proportionnée
un phénomène que nous ne pouvons ignorer
je le dis à cette tribune comme
représentante d'un département meurtri
par l'islamisme en effet si nous
débattons avec une telle acuité du suivi
des condamnés pour terrorisme
c'est aux fins d'apporter un palliatif
aux deux enjeux qui défient l'autorité
de l'état et qu'il faudra tôt ou tard
affronter le sens de la peine et sa
proportionnalité et la physionomie du
milieu carcéral
le sens de la peine et sa
proportionnalité d'abord c'est au sénat
que nous devons l'instauration d'une
peine incompressible de 30 ans et la
limitation drastique des conditions
d'aménagements de peine il nous faut
désormais aller beaucoup plus loin ne
serait ce qu'au regard des nouveaux
profils auquel nous avons affaire
le terrorisme est de plus en plus
juvénile son traitement pénal
ne peut l'ignorer
nous savons que les crédits de réduction
automatique seront supprimées si le
projet de loi dupond moretti est adopté
en l'état malgré tout c'est la question
de la perpétuité réelle que nous devons
aborder car ne nous y trompons pas la
compressibilité ne rime pas avec
enfermement asie je rappelle que le
droit interne britannique pourtant
inspiré par l'habeas corpus et dont
personne n'oserait dire qu'ils piétinent
les droits de la défense ne permettaient
ni élargissement me réexamen des peines
de perpétuité réelle jusqu'à ce que le
juge européen néglige la clarification
d'un droit pourtant souverain les
juridictions ne doivent pas être
contraintes à offrir aux condamnés une
perspective de libération dangereuse
pour la société
deuxième à la traiter la physionomie du
milieu carcéral
l'instauration de cette perpétuité
réelle dès le prononcé paraît d'autant
plus nécessaire que la prison est
marquée par une spécificité
démographique notable selon le dernier
numéro des cahiers d'études
pénitentiaire l'âge moyen des personnes
détenues était en france d'environ 35
ans soit 13 ans de moins que celle de la
population générale
les condamnés pour terrorisme n'échappe
pas à cette réalité bien au contraire il
n'est que de rappeler l'âge des cinq
derniers terroristes ayant frappé en
france pour comprendre le défi
générationnel qui est le nôtre 36 33 et
30 ans pour ceux de rambouillet charlie
hebdo et colombes 21 ans pour
l'assaillant de nice et seulement 18
pour le terroriste de conflent mes chers
collègues c'est aussi le djihadisme
d'atmosphère décrit par gilles kepel que
nous devons aujourd'hui défier or sans
suivi des détenus terroristes relais
potentiels d'une idéologie qui croient
souvent en prison c'est notre jeunesse
que nous exposons cette proposition de
loi s'attaque donc courageusement
dommages collatéraux d'un phénomène qui
constitue un défi pour notre
civilisation nous traitons aujourd'hui
les conséquences d'un mâle dont il
faudra très vite arracher les racines le
travail sera long car ses racines se
propage pernicieusement jusque dans nos
prisons je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la discussion
générale est close nous passons
maintenant à la discussion